hello what's up what's going on guys um
we are going to be playing some super
combo Man Cha I'm Mary I'm joined by
Eric the lovely Eric T he's beautiful
he's talented he'll be doing the combos
if I fail beauty
Beast brains before
Beauty um this was a project I heard
about from interabang Justin uh gave me
a few codes not only just to play but
also to hand out so uh if you guys do a
a comment or two you're automatically
entered we're going to pick a a bunch of
you guys at the end of the show so
thanks for joining and thanks uh to
interbang and uh Adult Swim games for
making this cuz it exists and it's out
tomorrow I believe tomorrow that's
correct we're playing a day early so um
I guess we'll just kind of get right
into it I played a little bit just to
kind of test it out I played through the
tutorial level this is like his house
this is such a cute little game it's a I
would say it's super like Street Fighter
esque you totally are doing combos combo
moves and um fighting mechanic but it's
got this cute little sticker art style
so it's all bouncy yep you like that
bounce I do like that
bounce also you forgot to mention the
devs or the dev is actually in the chat
as well oh yeah um we do have um we have
a Dev maybe even two in the chat um that
can answer your questions so if you guys
have any specific questions that someone
who has been playing the game for the
last 45 minutes can't
answer then I would suggest throwing it
in the comment section and seeing if
they can answer it for you um they are
there they also said don't fail by the
way all right so my goal here is to not
fail um I just want to go through a few
things here with you I don't know if
we're going to go through the tutorial
level again um home and training were
kind of like they seemed like early on
levels that kind of help you understand
the basic mechanics there is like wall
jumping and parrying all sort SS
of Street Fighter esque is the song
still on I hear music I can hear music I
hear coino radio but you know that's
obviously not part of the game but no
this it's a very interesting fighting
game from the little bit that we got to
play you you did the house a little bit
I did the training a little bit um and
there's obviously the combo store where
there's more mov that's right so as you
play through you get coins which I think
you get to use in the combo store which
every one of these so funny like you
basically said are so reminiscent of
like Street Fighter esque the Fireball
the Kamehameha stomp Dash through um I
bought a defense up um I think that was
a part of the tutorial that they kind of
guide you to buy a few things and then
when you when you purchase them you get
to equip them and you get two Perks at a
time so but I only have the defense at
this time so we'll kind of obtain more
as we go and then I also believe you can
just find stickers throughout the game I
think they're little bonuses yeah
they're like little trophy card I'll try
to find them all right um but I'm gonna
start at the we've we've been debating
if this
is dodo or dodoo or I don't even those
are doo doo do doo do doo we don't know
do do do Coco I don't know we'll see
you're going to beat up more Doo so
we're going to start with task one and
see how it goes I'll show you guys some
of the basic mechanics chill he looks
real hype you chill out your mom's
biscuit ain't ready yet he's loading man
he's like know he's loading up he's
ready to go I like that
um what's on that soda machine feel I
don't know oh struggles oh my name is
struggles by the way I like that name
what's the fanny packs must find all the
buttons and push them you know the fanny
pack does talk um task start I can't
remember so I had to wait for him
to
uh talk to me again maybe I'll figure it
out sounds like it's a three-word thing
it's do do Co so that's that's the
proper way apparently do do do doo do
doo yeah so it's like three separate oh
no he's stuck behind the barrel yeah you
got to help him
out oh sweet combo woo so uh yeah you'll
notice I have like uh currently I have
like a standard attack and then I got
this Fanny Pack Attack which is pretty
cool it's got a little bit of a cool
down so I can't spam it uh um what else
do I have there is a Parry if you kind
of O and I also have a defensive bubble
here um which I didn't use effectively
okay you're showing it off oh nice and
then you get these little copper coins
when you smash stuff uh and I think it
also even gives you some I I think I saw
a banana I assume that gives me Health
makes sense you know um there's some
cool moves that I should be practicing
right now as it's sending out all these
workers
um oh there was a Parry right there so
parrying is you pressing forward when
they're
attacking um you also have that double
jump later see that was fanny pack H
Fanny Pack Attack is pretty clear like I
think there there was an item thing or a
power up Parry or not power not Parry a
power up that you can equip later that I
think was infinite smash which seems
kind of
crazy but we'll see if we can afford it
later can't believe I'm already almost
out of Health here I got to be careful
bananas I need some bananas b a n a n a
s some bananas oh no he's coming after
me oh coin I'm not sure how the currency
functions yeah at first um you get like
the bronze ones which to me makes feel
like it's going to be one and then
there's gold ones which should be worth
more but then first get up get up so I
can hit you um oh oh no I died no you're
still good make a last I got to make you
got to find
finite amount of life last but then
there's blue coins and my immediate
reaction is was
that it's dooo money I we always get
yelled at like uh anytime we have like a
few we got Europeans Australians we got
all sorts of people in this office and
like the only people oh my God what's
that blue coin see woo what's that worth
it looked like
20 we're like America is the only place
that has only green
monies oh God I hope there's a banana
true that can't that can't be true no
ban I feel like there's there's green
currency in other countries no they have
green but we're the only ones have only
green like we just like so you're not
counting coins then cuz our coins are
copper and silver yeah I guess I'm not
count oh I got a sticker I feel like I
didn't earn that
sticker well some stickers are like
harder to get than others like the one
you saw me earlier uh I had to do like a
double jump into you know like a a wall
jump to get to it and uh because time I
just kind of skipped it I need that
money so I think the money disappears
after a certain amount of time so I want
to try to get it as most money does you
know oh now we're getting deep this
there's some serious personal commentary
going on can those hammers hurt me I
would assume so hey that's a new enemy
type right there it's not your typical
yellow hat he hit me he h he pointed at
you and laughed at you for getting
die smash oh you should smash that box
down there I think there's which box all
that said that that you got to smash the
silense so you got an infinite smash now
keep smashing I can just smash forever
like without uh cool down yeah oh look
at that all day feel like I'm kind of
wasting it on these boxes I'll pick up
that Candi corn looking I'm trying
trying to get that candy corn I think
it's candy corn I assume oh get out of
here oh there's a lot of questions um
our first try them as best as I can but
we do have two devs we have a Swim games
in there um we do as long as yeah I saw
I saw it earlier awesome okay I'm trying
to master this double jump here I think
it's like inter agent almost like like
the
oh okay I thought was like a play onent
sorry I'm totally like talking over so
I'm almost at full health so I'm not
going to open up any of those boxes cuz
I assume there's like a banana in there
later which I might need a double glove
thing right there I might need that
later like now oh
okay oh no they be throwing the hammer
straight up hammers at me double damage
I got a double damage room yeah that's
what you got oh scrub tacular you're
scrub tacular scrub tacular these guys
are scrub tacular you got to step up
your combo game there's scrubs yeah I
hear scrubs give me them blue coin two
piece plus biscuit oh that's a great
that's a great buy by the way two piece
and biscuits pop five
99 on a Tuesday sorry sorry what were
you going to say I don't know I wasn't
going to say anything quit throwing them
hammers got to kill the purple dude
purple hat I want that money he can
throw those fairly far can you parry the
hammer I don't know I think I would
assume smash oh
man I like that um in air fanny pack
move that I get oh I'm almost dead I
need get out my way Dr his body with you
I really need buy some soda or something
can you buy some soda I don't think you
buy soda I think you get everything you
need in these sweet sweet crates the
doco crates some candy corn for the road
little come on fridge open up I like the
way that looks I like that animation
throw my fany
pack pop it who is that Mega Man or some
Mega Man look
like excuse me it's homage yes homage to
street fighting characters and other
action heroes get up get up so I can
pound you oh nastic step it up oh I
don't think I can get that candy corn
roll for it I don't I think I have a
roll get it I want it send the fanny
pack oh it's even taunting you it's
making fun of me it's making fun of you
oh God I want to eat you sorry see you
later it's all right it's all right
there's plenty of more there's probably
candy corn in here
maybe he's stupid oh he called you
stupid did he yeah I heard him say I
can't hear
it I could get away from me could you
candy corn right into the belly right
into how come you had more coins just
now where did it all go I swear you had
like 300 something what do you mean like
when I look oh it's 700 that's why I am
just blind you're mixing up your sevens
and your ones man just completely blind
don't mind
me oh no he knocked me out he knocked me
out cold get up in the air
yeah I like this oh combo I want to I
want to do this air
combo oh seea that's that's like the
ultimate oh my goodness he gone I
knocked him out of sent him out of the
screen oh man that's like that WWE stuff
special move do that a see you later
knocked him into next look this guy oh
oh man what kind of construction action
site is this oh to like catch you up on
the story okay um I think my name is
struggles yep and uh I got a little bro
slap boxo sorry and he I think I'm
running out of I can't pay my mortgage
so I had to get a job so this is
my this is my job okay is uh this
construction site and for whatever
reason I like am hurting all the other
construction workers they're just in the
way of you making money you know it's a
Cutthroat life is that how construction
I don't know that's why all the
construction projects take so long is
because they're constantly fighting each
other little do you know there's you
know there's those few guys on the edges
doing stuff and then everyone inside's
like fighting for a
job I just want to destroy this bre that
porta potty P for this candy
corn oh you know what I wonder if that's
a SE up there yeah no I don't know no I
think I feel like this this is the kind
of game that's riddled with Secrets
because they have oh don't touch that
you can get shocked you just don't learn
huh it's killing me you don't hear it
crackling oh my gosh I'm going to die
don't fail don't fail don't fail the
stream oh it's
okay oh he killed me oh no he took all
your money he took my money he took like
200 of it I need that for my
mortgage I've got children actually I
don't he's my younger
bro that's kind of like having children
someone you got to take care
of look this guy with his heart tattoo
real bad a does it say mom on it I don't
know what it says oh we killed him too
quick we'll find out if you screw up
again which won't happen
so hopefully he didn't love life cuz I
just killed his
ass so if I knock that guy into the um
electricity would that I think so I I
would assume so oh is that what I'm I'm
supposed to knock him into the but I
understand I didn't even get that the
first time I was just playing I was
playing willy-nilly you got to read the
signs that's what the signs is there for
I don't think struggles reads oh my
goodness I play games all the way like I
am this guy okay I got you oh gosh so
you get really into character
oh bionic arm I like how strong the game
makes me feel like when I do a combo
correctly I feel pretty powerful which I
think is cool like when you booted that
guy off the screen when I smashed that
guy to death I felt really good about
myself
awesome oh just oh man you look stupid
kid oh man so like I got to watch my
life bar I get so excited to smash these
dudes that I got to be careful us that
Parry that sweet
Parry I want you're more of a street
fighter man actually I am you're pretty
familiar with it I'm going to make you
play the next round just so we can see
the different play Styles cuz what I
assume about this game also is that it
changes based on what how the person
plays yeah how good you are at playing
oh yeah you got to get some more D Doo
guys I think I have to smash yeah yeah
oh I I think it killed me that was dumb
so it opened up oh I see so I got to do
it
again I think I think because
I oh there you go what about that one
the next one oh oh y mhm downward smash
e oh get away from me I hate you oh
through the cinder blocks did I get in a
secret area I don't know
maybe oh you're getting real bold there
I am
like I wonder cuz I assume
he's he's going to kill me just keep
paring him yeah forever Parry man that
that yell is like that John Claude
vanam Blood Sport I got to be careful
I'm like out of I know that but I'm like
out of
freaking money over there I want that
money oh I think you got to do another
guy to bounce him in yep there you go oh
there's a lot of sweet coin over there
though that guy's going to totally
murder my butt your brother is like dude
we need that money is there a candy corn
in there it flew away it flew away it's
it's on the ground I need that candy
corn man oh you got some you got
some all the all this sweet candy corn
you can
go all right what is the what does the
tattoo
say keep going I don't know I got to be
careful you tell me I can't see it's
it's in small
curses rub fantastic is that like the
dookoo right there is that a secret oh
there's a sticker
there did you see that secret yeah I
think I think you on something secret
slew of coins I think this world is
riddled with Secrets but you got to be
oh like that oh I think you missed it
though I think it's too late I don't
think I can get up there there's
stickers up there
too man where's that Save State yeah I
should have had that guy kill me I think
I could actually get in there if I redid
the
game there'll be more time for coins
though I believe in the
future I agree plus I mean I'm already
richy rich here oh no man that fireball
C 3,000 coins so you got to have like
some kind of if I was a superhero which
in many ways I am okay um I should have
some kind of Catchphrase about my fanny
pack right sure like eat Fanny or
something but I heard
that Fanny in other oh man here we go in
other countries means something else oh
no I'm gonna die what do you mean well I
heard I heard fanny pack is actually
pretty rude is it yeah like but right
like the fanny well that's what I
thought but I was
wrong I think fanny can mean more than
just that more than that I think it can
mean weird
stuff I do
I'm not going to go there folks I'm just
not uh that's not going to happen I
think I want to get through there but I
can't yeah oh yeah sure you can oh he
thre me dead and he pointed at you oh
but you can do the secret part all right
all right maybe that was it was all part
of the plan I did that on purpose yeah
totally get up so I can beat the
out of you oh man come on man he's a
real bad a look at that tattoo you get
up you get up dark Mary's coming
out this what I like when I play Street
Fighter oh man
get go go all right I don't have a lot
of time you
don't
don't all right it was a good effort I
probably wouldn't have got there either
I want to get up there so badly I yeah I
don't think you can do a second wall
jump maybe it's a thing you got to
buy and that's probably like uh yeah I
don't think I can double jump on that
little piece each level has so annoying
um like a grade or whatever like there's
like a silver cookie a bronze cookie and
a gold cookie that's right I don't think
I'm going to get any kind of gold cookie
for time because I'm doing really bad
with time on this level I'm sure part of
it too is like the replay value is
sometimes you need maybe you need like a
skill or something to help you get some
of those Secrets get up soone smash you
through that
door oh no I like how you look when you
get hit what do you mean like my yeah
like got that Simpsons feel you know
what I was going to say uh the opening
level was so reminiscent of Dr Seuss I
couldn't not say that like it's got very
familiar how do you feel I think you
have to do the same thing we were doing
before so
it's um it's about hitting that guy into
that
pillow see and then into that I
think but I'm having a
oh you
freaking CRA oh he's got to keep going
up you got to keep you got to keep more
you got to keep shocking them until he
gets up to the button I think you'll be
fine get up there yeah get back up there
have some
more get up there oh he's is he just
stuck can I get in there I think you can
get in there as long as you don't jump
up
oh ah I thought you were going to kick
him into the that would been
great speed hurts this really hurts this
really hurts all right I got
to
oh great timing on that by that's a
really good feeling I'm not going to lie
double damage double
damage let's do some work do work get
wrecked oh no I died you're losing all
the money man I am losing money your
little brother is screwed all right all
right I might have you take over if I
can't make this one cuz I really
want I want to try to get this double
this this money up here if I can't do it
I got to pay attention to my life meter
I think it goes pretty fast I'm getting
I'm leaving myself open to to murder
here all right all right I'm trying I'm
trying you broke I F broke the wrong box
well it's all right all right I'm not
playing this correctly well it's first
time first day you
know all
right yes you can play with ar arcade
stick yes I wouldn't see why you
wouldn't be able
to oh he hit me with a hammer oh man
he's just talking crap I like this
purple hat
guy what is he saying I can't hear him
you can't tell when you're actually like
I can't walk past them I wish I could
walk through them Dash you need that
Dash move that we didn't buy yet we did
not buy it yet it's like 2000 I'm going
to beat the out of that guy I'm so
sick of him his his twin brother by the
way is back you might see his triplet oh
I hate that guy might have a quadruplet
brother I can't believe they keep coming
out hey it's Doo we justed about time I
get hit with one of these stupid hammers
sick of it gut ow I can't get him to
come
through see how I'm like I'm leaving
myself so susceptible to hammer damage
here do you see this like I'm almost
dead acally prone got a Cheo though oh I
like that oh that's that's not it's not
looking good kill me it's not looking
good Mary I know I'm like maybe you
should combo into the smash you're not
pushing him far in enough now I
up or you could game over I could game
over I'll trade you all right let's see
if I can I can do any
better oh man I don't like I don't like
that guy he shouldn't be taunting me
like that I'm the worst Construction
Company guy ever
worker I just assume they're called
Construction Company guys got to find
all the buttons and push them task start
I have no idea why all the game
companies are in San Francisco I know
sorry goob you're not all in San
Francisco
well there's a lot here but there's also
like major game companies in Seattle and
um there's a lot of there's a lot of
them in Austin Texas I mean San
Francisco isn't all
that all right you tell me what your
Technique is that's so much better than
mine my technique is to press the
buttons faster and press forward a lot
because that parries you're definitely a
street fighter person oh yeah awesome
I'm not a scrub give me them Co points
I'm such a scrub be two workers come
on oh that solar plexus punch you don't
want to get punched
there H eat up his dead body scrub
tacular I'm not
scrub I know I think I associate scrub
with negative like if you're crap at the
game you're a scrub yeah exactly so when
they say scrubtastic are they talking
about the bad guys cuz they're so
they're so bad that they're scrubtastic
cuz you're wiing them so hard no it's
that's how bad your combo is like bad is
in good no like you're a scrub if you
can only get a 10 10 hit combo I
see so how high when you get to like 30
30 was awesome you just becomes awesome
yeah but I'm all about the two-piece
biscuit man who doesn't like the
two-piece
biscuits I try to get a McDonald's
sponsorship I'm going to try to get
Popeye sponsorship two-piece biscuit
that's what they're going to call
me all
right yeah I mean I think I think the
thing you weren't doing enough was
pressing the forward Parry yeah you got
to treat it like Batman like Arkham
right like you got to get in their face
yeah you got to do that Parry you got to
say where is
he where is
he are you double tapping forward to
Parry no you just press forward once
when they're about to attack I think you
can even turn to the other
guy how high your health bar is compared
to mine wish they got up faster cuz when
you smash them like the first thing I
want to do is continue smashing them I'm
I'm I'm guessing there's like a like
maybe if you do that downward smash I
just did while yeah there you go you can
hit them in the ground if they do
downward
smash
a no
oh this is a this Rod this uh steel rod
thing is too strong for one smash
infinite punch how long do you get
infinite punch you think I think it's
just for a short duration maybe like 30
seconds no all my coins better get
through there I need my coins go get my
BL they're
blinking all right so now you're close
to
where I was oh that was pretty good
combo
comboed him into the fanny yeah oh yeah
see that oh smash him on the ground
don't give him a chance oh two-piece
biscuit where's the rest of guys got
that double damage double
damage oh oh am I supposed to do this
yeah do an upward yeah do an upward
Fanny call me stupid he did call you
stupid I don't understand what
construction company is like this the
Doo the doo Construction
Company yep like they're all oh you're
going to lose that blue
coin nice he moved his dead body get out
of my way I got coins to pick
up oh he's jump he bed you one
good I like you can knock them into each
other that's pretty rewarding so like I
think the only move you can hit them
with when they're on the ground is that
knock over like Domino's down the down
oh where did you come from oh he tossed
a hammer at
you they have significantly less life
though oh good they're pain in the butt
give me that
coin I get checkpoint yeah who's that
that guy looks like real badass man I
want to be that guy's friend is friend I
assume he's I got a box on my head it is
on your
head come on man I didn't use a smash
it's my
fault you're taking
forever hey at least you're alive I'm at
4 minutes at least you're alive I
believe you were at like 15 I think I
was but I was getting all the secrets oh
hey I am willing to go pick those
up like I broke the box and didn't think
I go pick up those coins little did he
know I'm
broke oh oh he bopped you good those
hammers are hard to dodge they're way
fast
oh see you I should probably go break
that other
boss oh I can't go back don't beat on
him he just wanted to use the bathroom
that guy he doesn't even have a
chance like I just went to the bathroom
man is that where he came out of yeah
the Porta pot that seems a little rude
to beat someone up right totally
going
oh what you know about my fanny pack if
you smash the porter potty enough it
breaks into awesome
candy which as we all
know must have got it from the guy that
just exited the uh porta potty
right yeah through trial and error you
know how to do all the things that I
already have yeah I know I got to I get
I got to watch and witness how to play
the game whereas you had to show me the
way we Eric will pull this off he's like
Street Fighter Guru but I do want to
play the next level oh see you and your
friend I want awesome yeah like back
knowledge of porter
potties the power to help us this go
that gold yeah look at that I think you
went here too though I assume I did it
looks like you have
to scrub
scrub and a biscuit smizzle
smizzle my shizzel hey how come did it
work oh you can't get that coin it's so
sad you know you can down jump to get
through some of those damn it I think
that's what it was I think you're right
okay you should be able to go now how is
he not dead I don't know forget him oh
there he goes oh he's got a lot of coins
well they're copper man everyone knows
copper are like the bottom feater of
coins oh my goodness you get 100 copper
you get you get one dollar dollar dollar
bills dollar dollar bills y'all got to
when you get enough copper You Can Make
It Rain copper making him move at all
you got to smash him through there oh is
that okay yeah my
bad you never use your combo your like
your fan a packing enough really I feel
like you don't it's up it's that one
yeah it's why it's Y and you never use
your guard either your guard is your
left bumper I'm all about per no I'm all
about Perry which one's
guard your guard is your left see you
just I wasn't pressing forward
enough oh solar plex is punched stun him
right in the gut use your hips ah
jerk I need that the real short youin
the one with the fire fire
uppercut that moves the best that one is
cool um I think it's really hard to hit
them in the air I like typically can't
get them them in the air as much as I do
a little speed run here oh snizzle oh
that was good you really earned that
smizzle I'll tell you that right
now or Sizzle not
snizzle you think aw it's like Snoop Dog
came up with all the words for this
video game Snoop Lion or whatever his
new Snoop name is I believe it's dog
again is it I think so so apparently at
30 you get the uh you get your little
perky thing you need to hit the left
button I press all the buttons that's
correct exactly what you must
do man you got
Hammer nice now go down doing good that
guy has to go through the right wall
biscuit but you could just kill him and
then I think there's a secro to your
left you think so yeah I think so I'm
calling it are we doing that calling it
where's the secr oh what is
that stuff down there are the Rocks
secret I thought there was other stuff
why would they let you go all the way
back to the left but there's no secret I
don't know to make you think there was a
secret watch out your like health is low
careful I'm a
boss is that what you said before you
almost like died time see those three
pares I just did oh freaking Batman
right now all day oh you stay down where
is
he besid I hit a checkpoint oh this is
all right this is
where go get up there yeah got that
sweet I don't know what that was looked
like a Moonie a sticker of some kind
we'll have to find it
later seea seea I wouldn't want to
be that move is the best oh candy corn
got to get it to get that sweet sweet
candy corn watch that's not candy corn
did they tell us yet if it's C know can
I ask officially what that is that we're
considering is candy
corn I have no idea it could be Pizza
the other one was um the first
um food that I got was a banana I
remember
that so interesting wall jump
no
oh man smashed him
good I got to do this
H freaking Hammer throws dude come
on I think you got to jump through the I
got to block that I think yeah hit your
block use your block left
bumper get over there I'll taste coins
Here
Comes are you farming Y no I'm trying to
get him up there it feels like you're
farming for money a sweet sweet currency
that's something I would do throw in the
air dead try
again I'm killing him too fast I know I
wish there was you're so strong Eric
that's the problem I think is happening
is that you're just too
strong please come
on
oh yeah maybe I'm just are you hitting
forward when you're yeah I'm pressing
forward smash
attacking Z like he's like bouncing
they're having bad
bounces maybe you have to get him
closer on the plus side you have a crap
ton of
money oh come
on I heard that laugh
production screw you guys you've killed
like 30 of them they just keep coming
out of a he so close I'm about to go
punch that thing myself you can't you'll
die you I think you're hitting them up
dude I think you're doing it wrong you
know you can't do that you're going to
die I can hit the first
one oh he's got a lot of coins though
all right all right all right I'm
bored you got to knock himine you're
knock him up well I died here last time
I'm pressing forward that's a forward
punch that's Falcon
Punch probably getting a text right now
like you're bad at this
game oh yeah slap it all chuckle it all
I'm going
die yeah shut up shut your face just
going to drink my tea while while I
watch this okay well well you're you're
not done yet you're not done yet one hit
and you're dead yeah yeah how do you
feel now why don't you show me how to
play this game I did do it I did do it
though I I did do it fine fair enough
you did it you did do it but I I got you
there did you sort of oh got to Parry
that
stuff maybe we should do like a com get
you there maybe that's what this game's
really about is the combo the true combo
com of both T and Mary working together
I'm liking it a collaboration of sorts
Super Slam I want a Super Slam down but
I don't think I have that move yet the
Candy Corn are you worried about the
Candy Corn yeah it's your
life oh I forgot to read the comments if
that was actually real yeah yeah we just
got we just got told you better read
it all right let's see how many buttons
used in this game looks like it's about
four or five 1 two three four oh look at
that four four with
block yeah I should have stuck my pinky
in the air when I drank the uh the
tea uh let's see suck
Fanny I don't know if that's appropriate
to say suck Fanny why why isn't it
appropriate I know uh how many upgrades
are available in the game it looked like
there's quite a few U moves that you
could get as well as the um little bonus
perks uh I'd say at least
six to eight more that we don't have
like there's haduken there's a dash
there's a stronger like uppercut
move
um yay checkpoint let me see if there's
a Mac release I'm not did you see that
yeah I got oh no who's that oh they got
axes axemen oh you beat that one part
yeah okay I did it while you were
yapping well I fair enough I got no
rebuttal oh they got like a shield they
do have a shield so do I it's a little
bigger than my bub yeah man I'll just
knock them into each other ch ch
ch they got nothing on the smash
though oh they did hit me got me
good let see hopefully
there's oh it's so weird when I can
smash through the floor like that
because I'm not sure if you know Mar is
this is this going to be a Mac 2 or just
PC first oh you know what that's a good
question for the devs look at the steam
page we're playing it on PC page right
now I assume it's on Mac PC and Linux
but I honestly I can't say that
for I only see system requirements let
me see if I let me just do a contr f
here I don't see Mac on there but I look
at this check my dco check oh you beat
the level sick pick up all the sweet
coin where is it what the hell I didn't
get any money because we died so many
times I think I think we still got 1,700
let's go buy a new ability how about
that all right let's buy let's do that
good job on the combo I don't think we
did super hot oh we did good neic link
says do you have Shield Envy
Mary I did have Shield EnV I have a
shield too but theirs was a little
bigger so as we all
know um the size of your
Shield is what
matters makes all the difference except
for the motion
of your fanny oh
okay oh wait no did I why am I redoing
this level I don't want to redo all this
level uh I think I accidentally I
restart it on accident little exit I
think You' be ex restart again amateur
amateur hour only one of us saw you're
really good at punching people through
and up that little Corridor but but menu
options are another another story my old
Nemesis did you just hit resume okay all
right so I got some I assume those are
cookies interesting there's like bronze
silver and gold cookies I think they are
cookies cuz like in the sticker store
thing there's cookie or something also
which um a lot of people missed in
struggles house I said to my brother
that I would bring him home cookies so I
think that's why but I don't know anyone
who wants silver or gold or bronze
cookies
in fact the only one that looks like a
cookie is bronze like that one genuinely
looks like a cookie what are you going
to buy we have 8,000 all right you tell
me also in the chat if you guys if
there's any specific thing that you're
like heck yeah we can get that but we
are going to get the one that you want
the most so you pick one and then the
chat can pick the other one providing we
can afford them both go back up so we
got grab that's the one I want fire
uppercut that's what I want spinning
Lariat I like like the way that looks
it's like
the no it's like this I can't I can't
you can't my arms are getting cut off
but it's kind of like if you can imagine
my all right so it's like pile driver I
like the sound of that um just kidding
good wants the come
Fireball Stomp The Fireball is there a
dive kick there's no dive KCK Dash
through you see an actual dive kick what
is it was there a dive kick there was no
dive KCK there is a dive
kick yep we already bought that that was
the first thing I bought what down down
B I must not be using that wow we'll use
that next time good to know uh I say get
that that's what I want get what you
want so that's been purchased some said
Fireball someone said spinning
Lariat there's no consensus there's no
consensus not at all let me go look at
the other spinning Larry spinning Larry
huh we can buy this someone said
Fireball so that's two for Fireball
someone also said never mind get Lariat
uh can we afford both isn't the lariat
1700 I can't afford both I'm going to
get the spinning larat all right because
we have a fireball so now we have two
maybe go buy the we didn't buy the
fireball we bought the fire uppercut but
uh that's what you wanted yeah yeah so
you can buy your second perk though what
do you want it to be so I noticed do
that oh I can buy a perk in my abilities
uh it's those yellow ones that's right
so I noticed we got the defense up when
I got the 30 combo so it seems like you
only get your perk when you hit a
certain combo number so we can't afford
the
spaz you can't afford half of these we
can afford the heel Parry which actually
would be pretty helpful consider that's
something you need
oh shots been
fired all right I need that so they they
said they were going to support the game
for Linux in the future so it look kind
of like a PC thing
first incorrectly for now for now um
this is one of the stickers I got I just
want to make sure everybody gets to see
those I don't know what is it I don't
know I called that a it's a lemon cookie
for your face what
that for your face
hole these are like little
M as if a lemon cookie wasn't enough
here's a a bag of full ooh man they must
really like lemon cookies this whole
thing is is very cookie centered but
just like that song I did it all for the
cookie did you come
on the
cookie are you sure it was the cookie no
I don't think anybody said that ever it
was a
close I would say the rest of the words
but I don't remember
them
oh you're breaking all their boxes boxes
we need some boxes here task isn't he
worried man those boxes are fancy
boxes can I knock on this door you got
smash it yeah there you go smash it to
open they just W oh they closed it jerks
they walked through it oh
yeah I want to use my things good thing
we looked them up huh good thing we
looked up how to use the oh that's my is
that my spinning Lariat I don't know
that's that's definitely not your
spinning
Lariat I thought I did it
I know dive kick was like down down B in
the air probably I thought my kick my
Fireball was um forward forward B is it
am I crazy try it that's a dash of some
sort that's a Parry I beat the crap out
of that guy but I still want to know
what my bonuses are all right let me try
to see if I can look up the
moves see do you see
that yeah what is that oh that's the
spinning Larry yeah yeah yeah okay I'm
just going back and forth and hitting X
but I don't know if that's correct so
maybe your first move is like the first
rotation of the lariat and then the
second one yeah oh there it is how'd you
do that well I'm hting back and forth
and hitting me that's pretty fancy move
sticker oh
man fanny pack that guy is terrifying oh
I didn't even see him I was so uh you
were so into my moves my sweet hot moves
yeah I was looking at the
sticker oh look at that guy he's got the
uh what what construction tool is that
see guys my lar larot though bam oh man
you can get big combo numbers with that
just keep doing that all day all
day all day man oh you're going to lose
it give that don't lose it don't lose it
a you lost the comb cuz I got hit yeah
the moment oh there it is fire from my
hands is it so is it down up that down
up be that down up it is down
up all of you guys know I'm a I'm a Ken
player that's my go-to move right there
the the dragon punch oh no I did it the
wrong way see you can easily do
it oh I countered it oh my goodness he
killed me with all my fancy moves I
think I'm so excited to use my moves
that it's bad haven't been trained yet I
haven't been properly
trained it's like it's like you bought a
book that told you how to do it but you
haven't actually like gone through the
motions of doing it so I feel like I'm
getting
stronger and where are all the
dudes do I not have to kill them again
uh I don't know I think I think the uh
the bigger dude I think is like a mini
boss so I guess maybe when you kill him
he's gone I think I just saw some
pricing information from pH pawns $199
tomorrow and 14.99 after that so it's on
sale little sale
action if my Math's correct that's oh no
I'm getting
wed I'm getting wed here got use that
Parry that sweet Parry well he's he's
stronger no he's not the same guy that
you fought earlier St um my fanny isn't
working oh wait not using it
properly my Fanny's broke oh is it
that's not good that's not a good thing
when your f is
broken oh man so if you do down smash
ooh he's chopping Lumber he CH where in
the construction would you ever need an
axe
though oh eat that sweet banana you
don't want to get cramps I do you don't
want to get cramps I'm I need more
pottassium yeah come here nanner oh no
oh what even happened there no that's
fine them in the next stage yeah that's
right it just like
pick up that banana is that like is that
is that the big boss guy right there
it's got to be right which guy the guy
in the
sign um back there don't worry about it
just concentrate yeah that sweep PA do
it again oh he tried get stunned oh
there you go oh he's got that hey Shield
doesn't look that big this
time I'm already on half health I need
more nanners They smash in that box for
me Sid Bird's saying uh you should uh
possibly go to the doctors to get that
broken Fanny checked
out you wish I like my fanny just the
way it is thought you just said it was
broken no oh man friendly fire that guy
is not having it oh no I was facing the
wrong way cover up cover
up oh man that guy is not messing around
no he's not look a jackhammer taking
Jackhammer all right monitor the chat
you think it's the pile dry how do I do
the how do I do this I like saying the
word potassium too how do you did you do
the spinning larious oh it was like left
and right with B but I was having a hard
time doing it correctly without getting
it without getting hit a few times I
think is the problem I'm having oh my
goodness I'm getting W you're getting
wted forgot to oh I got tired maybe why
don't you H beat these guys first and
then practice move that way you're not
just getting wed
on your where's my auto par heel thing
you're not looking so hot that I was
telling you that you needed and in
reality I needed it look at you look at
your sorry butt why don't you practice
no it's fine all right whatever you're
going to
die well good job Eric I didn't get my
Batman swag on my t-piece and a
biscuit all right now for
real said down up down up and
B you're not using B you're using X oh
really
interesting my fanny wa where was that
down down oh there's the dive kick all
right I didn't even know B was a button
well you didn't even
look you've been we've been buying them
so your original buttons okay are all X
and Y like that but now that you have
now that I know that b is a button just
and I was pressing a that or the least
we could ask is that you just don't die
before I you know before you get laugh
strong I think you got to smash that guy
I kind of took a lot of damage to learn
that lesson so well this is your last
life so we got to do this mother assing
thing all over again so he's not doing
the lar yet get your
together like your new moves are cool
but you're using them without defense
it's like that one movie where got
defense that one guy buys the the little
book he learns like the super Palm move
he tries to use it against the kids
beating up assume you mean the never-
Ending Story no it was um I can't even
remember the open those boxes and get
some nanners you're about to kick yeah
well you got to get rid of the problem
oh you're going to die you know the
confidence you're displaying in me is
really helping me want to I'm
unimpressed
suceed get that boot oh you got to do
this oh that was cool get up there
there's a secret up
there why isn't why isn't there any food
up there though need some sweet bananas
I'm cramping up eat a
sticker oh thanks oh secret area secret
area what was down what was down below I
don't know we'll never
know risky risky proposition
uh I think you got to knock him into
that pillow oh great this is this is
where I that one where you're really
good at where I
shine really dude try not hitting a
button and just hitting y like in not a
left or right two piece and a biscuit
two piece and a biscuit two piece in a
Biscuit that's what I'm all about two
piece in bisc okay there's a there's a
special up there there's a sticker I
don't know who that is that's my
girlfriend that's my lady friend hey got
to get her sticker to to meet her
yeah please have some type of potum ss
so
inapo get down there want some spinning
hilarious oh no oh you're going to
die no you can't die cuz we're out of
um can you calm down for a second no
thanks guy who's that guy no you're not
part of the construction crew he's not
part of the construction crew where how
where did that stuff just come from I
don't know that guy is
terrifying game over if I talk like Dr
Seuss we wouldn't that just be like
talking and rhyme my spinning Lariat
talk like doctor was not a
go-to all right hit those oh that di
kick though do that again is that b down
down B when you're in the air so you
want to double jump and then do it are
you doing at an angle can you just do it
down it goes at an angle on its own how
do you know what angle you want it's
only what you face so it's like left or
right if I die here
yeah I get it too bad these boxes are
mine and I'm going to break them break
this whole place down you're going to
struggle with me cuz my name
struggles not scrubs you're scrubs oh
get fanny
packs need them
bananas put that Fanny right in their
faces oh man I don't have my
girlfriend's sticker anymore my lady
friend yeah you lost it cuz you
died we can obtain her again you won her
over before T again that's right that
felt good you stay down there 31 hits I
think as much as long as you're hitting
stuff you keep comboing which is a good
thing yeah I
think this game makes you feel really
powerful when the hits lands it can be
really stressful to get to get
bonked but when you're on you're on got
that sweet 50 hit nice look at that
combo look at that combo meter they're
going to have to start calling you combo
fiend combo
man oh dop get doped get doped up he's
hype he's a hype I got to eat some
bananas no my combo meter it's still
there oh I don't even want to play
anymore is that 65 do you think there's
an achievement for having a combo
throughout the entire level I don't well
in that case I don't know how you would
be able to pull that off cuz
in God why doesn't it do the sure you
can oh there you go oh wow you did it
you see that off
the is dive kick
stun oh that didn't go anywhere larat
I'm trying to Lariat every time I try to
Lariat I end up dying yeah see like
that's I agree like the lariat did not
do me any favors lar actually got me
killed I think every yeah I think
because we're not
good with our new moves yet is actually
causing us more
grief I do this no wrong
wayc you're going to get bonked he's
he's going to Bonk you one good I got
the schizzle though
schizzle that banana I see
it some B some of that banana need that
n good
nice nice
Lariat no
okay I need something to hit I need
something to
hit oh what was
that little little swan
kick get my cookie get that cookie what
kind of cookie is that then a vanilla
cookie oh oh I should have went down
yeah we forgot there's been no system to
this my
instinct nice good job got it on the
firsty your pro tip it was your pro tip
oh I'm going to go get my lady friend
sticker get
her love you girl I have no
idea yeah here's no context for this
lady sticker there will be oh yeah I
sure I think I need to block this guy I
think that's what that
is can't Parry everything sweet bananas
this where I died last time oh that
crazy guy's going to come out that axen
is like pretty tough and a biscuit
twopiece and a biscuit two piece and a
biscuit it's my
favorite there all right careful careful
careful he's got cap wait if you open up
some of those boxes there's probably a
nner in there think so I think so see
you later sucker we can't
jump what he doing what you going to do
he's going crazy he's going crazy down
there stop copying
me he's
insane
scr get him in the groin there's a
banner there's B nner there I'm trying
to get it he's in my
way stay down Cape man I'm just going to
call him Cape
man smash him into those
boxes like this he's dead
man you can you can kind of abuse their
dead bodies a little
bit
okay um somebody's asking why they're
fighting and I honestly don't think I've
been given too much context of why
everybody wants to kill me so
much
um I think it's because everyone wants a
construction job I think it's very
competive a secret up there well there's
what about oh look at those there's a
scker jumping is terrible skills could
use some work I only know how to mash
buttons ooh sticker can you get in there
oh yeah who's that is that your other
girlfriend oh no it's another kind of
cook your girlfriend on the side she's
the one that bakes the
cookies right so many cookie
girlfriends all right good good yeah
yeah hopefully new checkpoint new
checkpoint I apologize if uh this is a
little bit hot later a controller the
controll controller you make it you have
sweaty Palms yeah I'm getting a little
clammy that's how you know it's
definitely a street fighter Style game
is when the controller gets all Gro
giving you fair warning you got to get
him in there you're doing
it I know just press
y that good job now what oh it went away
gotcha what about that sweet coin though
go to the right you oh this
thing oh I lost money there you see I
did see that I did see where you
saddened by it where's my big check uhoh
oh they're throwing here knock them into
the other ones just hit Y without
hitting forward you're getting wed on
You Look
Silly
nice oh little do we know this is the
pro tip right here just press what oh I
wasn't pressing
forward I didn't Parry him
I was dying to the easiest guy it's
pretty embarrassing yeah I agree uh
warer I want a cookie this game makes me
want to eat cookies I need that is that
a
pair what are those that's new food it's
a new food
groupie scrub tacular scrub
tacular piece and a
biscuit oh you stayed out
o got a sticker smle smizzle
smizzle that's pretty good seeing you on
a lot of
enemies yeah yeah larat I want
the in your Dome oh there so many boxes
there get that blue get that blue left
left I need infinite smash or something
oh that's good too you're going to lose
this
money why they're all in
boxes oh look at all that money I don't
want to advance oh the check I saw the
check did you yeah I did is it within
reach oh yeah ham was that a ham I don't
know that's what I was saying it looks
like like a like a pear or
something oh
crap that yeah what is that oh dang it
we could even analyze I think it's a ham
no you see it right there maybe it's got
a little leaf to it it's got a little
leaf to it it's a brown
pear Doo
steaming pile of oh give me that money
Make It Rain baby all the coins give it
to me all right
um sorry got a little clamy okay all
right well you can you can buy another
do it all right let's see oh combo 63 I
only got a silver terrible we did die a
lot I think that was our time was pry oh
we high score me high score yeah how do
you get silver in a new high
score it's a really creepy trans hey
that's how you got to keep your coins
you got to keep your coins in your fanny
pack in your fanny you're going to lose
it all right what do you guys want to
buy don't know we got we only got 3.7
th000 3.7k we didn't do is hot in you
know why because we died we died twice
that other time and I think it just kept
all the gold anyways or the coin
what Bitcoin maybe that's Bitcoin is
that Bitcoin
stomp stomp falling so all of these are
uh B moves huh down and to the right is
B that's the fireball yeah quarter
Circle forward makes
sense all right we can buy that that's
all we can buy then it's up to you you
can buy whatever you want what I like
about the fireball is then we can do
like it's a distance so you can kill
people at a distance Ricky I don't think
I saw a spinning bird kick sorry there
is no no spinning bird
kick so uh that was super combo man huh
we did buy the
hoken hoken haduken haduken haduken
haduken
duen you didn't see Bonito did
you
yeah hi see I saw Bonito I ignored him
wow what a jerk I still want to know who
that is well there is some mystery left
this game um we didn't really get too
far we only got
two two little tasks in to the second
level but I kind of I'm curious to see
what else happens in this game I kind of
want to
just do what oh
I just watch that all day but
um
yeah oh I'm
excited can I only do it to the right or
can can I do it to the left as well I
think you're just bad at doing it to the
left shut up you know it's like yeah
it's like Zoolander he can only turn one
way that's kind of how you are with
Fireballs apparently yeah I did it all
right so I guess yeah what are your
final thoughts my final thoughts are I
think it's a fun beat them up um you
know definitely if you are interested in
what you saw uh it comes out tomorrow
believe it does come out tomorrow this
is the day before um I'm having a lot of
funing it I definitely think it's going
to take some practice for me to get to
get a little bit better at these moves
but it looks like there's a lot of room
for practice and fun and this so seems
like I have no idea how long it is but I
mean that's that was just to two
Tas solid hour so uh there's probably a
lot of gameplay in this uh it is fun so
uh I would recommend it was pretty good
uh if you guys have any other questions
you know definitely throw them down in
the comments oh I do believe we have
some codes to give away oh yeah I
totally watch forgot I almost forgot all
right we had questions too oh were those
the questions we weren reading such a
good job how about we read some of those
now because sorry Cynthia she must hate
me that's my fault I had the laptop most
of the time you did have the laptop most
of the time can you play as other
characters I don't think so um what
penalty is there for losing all your
lives you do die and then restart that
level task or whatever that task um will
there be a box version I don't think
so um Cynthia are these people she's mad
at me yeah we're we're actually reading
as who are the
winners I think it would be feasible to
play with the mouse keyboard it's
definitely possible um I've always had
trouble doing like for example you know
the the haduk motion or the fireball
motion is like a down forward it's a
little weird doing it you know with a
mouse keybo board probably the short
yukin's a little bit weird but I think
it it'll be fine I think it works
controller is probably the easiest it
feels like but you know you can
definitely do that of course we talked
about it earlier the stick is fine right
um could yeah yes you can play it with
the stick will this game be on mobile I
don't think so I think this is uh
definitely like a PC game
um let's see was this Kickstarter it was
kickstarted I think um I know it started
on Kickstarter I saw the kickstar it was
successful
um it wasn't that long ago and now it's
basically ready to go at this stage um
the combos somebody asked like sorry cut
but the combos actually like I said if
you hit 30 you get your first perk which
is our defense up uh that stays active
for a little bit I'm sure the higher you
get you'll get to your second perk so
you want to try to keep chaining things
you can chain combos off boxes too it's
not just the people that's right your
perks are enabled from your combo meter
so if you never raise your combo you
never get those perks so you have to
like learn to get better combos over
time um you can only enable Perks at the
end of the level so um when you're
buying things that's when you can enable
perks yep um you can enable two at a
time and you can buy I think like
probably like six or eight of them six
to eight I think there's like but then
you you can only pick two two of your
favorite ones and I think it's only
single player I don't think it's
multiple player so all right all right
I'm going to read off some names uh now
that we did that uh these are winners
you guys all want a free copy we'll
probably be giving these out tomorrow
when the game is out so please enjoy uh
desert Maverick
uh gr BB noodle legs I like that one uh
b Diddy Tampa sler sakat tum suic the
anti-hero
967 a oh wait just
kidding uh what is it aanati a a aat goo
Gooby goo one goo right uh Dijon ketchup
that's a nice one Ricky guitarist Ricky
maror man
04 Bob Jones
1980 um what are those last last couple
oh gam spot winner that's a gam spot
chat come on and then there's others in
the gam spot chat Spock 005 poly
pixelgon uh SF dvus and Broly B 593 you
guys are all winners woo um
where's mine I'm just kidding you just
played it so thank you guys for joining
us on this awesome chat I hope you had
fun watching us learn how to play uh and
we will see you next time on now playing
so thanks a lot
bye